>> Laura: I HAVE A LITTLE RING
THAT THEY GAVE ME LAST NIGHT.
IT IS THE MONDAY BEFORE
ASH WEDNESDAY.
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
50TH ANNIVERSARY RENDEZVOUS,
WATCHING MORE THAN 30 FLOATS AND
MARCHING BANDS COMING INTO THE
CONVENTION CENTER AT
NEW ORLEANS.
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE, ONE OF THE
SERIAL EXPERIENCES THAT YOU
REALLY HAVE TO SEE.
HE FOUND ANOTHER CREW DEDICATED
TO HONORING OUR VETERANS AND
TRANSFORMING THEIR LIVES.
WATCH.
♪ ♪
>> IN NEW ORLEANS, ALONG THE
MISSISSIPPI, A PREPARADE A PARTY
IS UNDERWAY.
THESE ARE MEMBERS OF A
THE HOST PARADES AND UNDERTAKE
PHILANTHROPIC WORKS THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR.
THEY WERE FOUNDED UP BY A GROUP
OF LAWYERS FROM NEW ORLEANS.
HE WAS ONE OF THEM.
>> A FEW OF US HAVE RETURNED
FROM ACTIVE DUTY OF SERVING, AND
THERE WERE NO CRUISE AROUND THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY HONOR JUST A
MILITARY.
AND WITH SO MANY PEOPLE SERVING
OVERSEAS, WE WANTED TO HAVE FUN,
BUT WE WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
THAT WOULD HONOR THE MILITARY.
A FALLEN SOLDIER, WOUNDED
WARRIORS, SO MANY THINGS.
>> THE ORGANIZATION ROLLING
THROUGH THE USE OF STREETS.
THIS ONLY ONE, DEDICATED IT TO
CELEBRATING AND POPULATED BY
VETERANS.
>> AS HE CAN SEE, RAIN OR SHINE,
THEY ARE ROLLING.
A LITTLE RAN COULD NOT STOP THIS
CREW.
MANY OF THE WRITERS HAVE SEEN
COMBAT IN IRAQ, AFGHANISTAN, AND
VIETNAM.
FOR SOME, IT IS NOT JUST A
PARADE, BUT AN EXPERIENCE OF JOY
AND HEALING.
FRED AND BILL SERVED IN VIETNAM
TOGETHER, BUT IT WAS THE LEGION
OF MOBS THAT REUNITED THEM AND
TO CHANGE THEM THE BETTER.
>> EVERYONE KNOWS HOW WE WERE
TREATED AND ALL OF THAT STUFF,
PTSD, SO MY WIFE'S THOUGHTS THAT
IT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA FOR ME,
PERSONALLY, TO JOIN A GROUP THAT
WAS CATERING TO VETS.
AND IT HAS.
IT HAS BEEN A BLESSING.
IT HAS KIND OF BROUGHT ME OUT OF
MY SHELL, GAVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET FOLKS.
AND I FEEL A LOT MORE
COMFORTABLE BEING AROUND
VETERANS.
AND ACTIVE MILITARY, SO WE NOT
ONLY GET TO INTERACT WITH PEOPLE
WHO HAD SERVED YEARS AGO LIKE
US, BUT WE ALSO GET TO INTERACT
WITH THE NEW PEOPLE, AND THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SERVING OUR
COUNTRY TODAY.
>> EVERY BRANCH OF THE MILITARY
IS HONORED.
AND BEFORE THE PARADE, SENSUAL
MENTION                 SPECIAL
MENTION IS MADE.
>> WE ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE PEOPLE WHO SPONSORED US.
THEY REALLY WENT OUT OF THEIR
WAY TO DO THIS FOR US.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATED
BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE FORGOT
THEY VIETNAM VETERANS.
>> BORN AND RAISED IN A
NEW ORLEANS, THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT I HAVE EVER RIDDEN IN
THE PARADE.
>> IT'S AMAZING HOW MUCH SUPPORT
WE GET FROM THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
PEOPLE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
MILITARY, AND THAT'S WHY IT IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR OUR MEMBERS TO
SEE THAT.
IT IS FANTASTIC.
>> OF ALL OF THE CRUISE, THE
LEGION OF MARS MAKES IT UNIQUE.
THIS CREW GETS SOMETHING BACK
FROM PARADE GOERS, THE RESPECT
AND GRATITUDE THAT THEY DESERVE.
FOX NEWS, REPORTING FROM
NEW ORLEANS.
>> Laura: THAT'S FANTASTIC.
THE FOUNDERS TELL US THAT THEY
NAMED THE CREW K-R-E-A W AFTER